What makes your favorite League of Legends champion your favorite?
Is it their kit, their viability in the meta, or did you fall in love with
their personality and their character?
Well voice lines play a huge part in how that character comes across to us on the Rift.
That's why I love playing Annie so much.
Have you seen my bear Tibbers?
You smell like, burning.
Beaten by a little girl.
That's why this week we’re counting down the top 10 league of legends champions based on their voice lines.
Now we’re gonna be fair with this one guys, one legendary one-liner
is not gonna land you at the top of our list.
We're taking into account a champion's entire repertoire,
of lines.
Now let's hear what the champions themselves have to say.
Kicking off our list at number 10 is the Glorious Executioner himself.
"Welcome to the League of Draven."
This egotistic narcissist has some of the most iconic voice lines in the game,
"Perfection? I got that."
"Draven's giving a master class in how to play Draven."
(Laugh)
which naturally, are all about himself.
"It looks like Draven's taking a Draven break."
"Not Draven, Draven."
And why wouldn’t they be?
"Let's check out our OP players of the game."
"Draven, Draven, Draven, Draven and Draven."
He may have teammates… but who cares about them?
Especially with this axe juggling death machine tearing up the lane .
"Draven throwing the other team a bone."
"Who wants some Draven."
"Let's check out our featured matchup of the day, Draven vs. some loser."
"Sjokz better interview me after this."
His flair for the dramatic makes his voice lines some of the most famous in League of
Legends.
"Draven was an excellent pick this game."
"And every game."
Earning this grim Noxian performer a spot on our list.
"Did you know Draven can catch another Draven's axes?"
"You should read the hits more often."
Quirky doesn’t even begin to describe the ninth entry on our list.
"A solid giggle should do the trick."
"Let's use all the colors."
Lulu takes the whimsy of the Yordles to a whole new level.
"Cuddly incoming."
"Never look a tulip in the eye."
Her cutesy, fanciful voice lines certainly break the tension, even in the most
dramatic of teamfights.
"I recommend skipping."
No matter how dangerous the situation, with a wave of her wand and some dubious magic
words the situation becomes, well, more cuddly.
"Adoribus."
"Delightify."
"Transmogulate!"
With Pix by her side, there’s nothing the Fae Sorceress can’t twirl through.
"I could go for a twirl... Whoa, whoa whoa ah, wooh!"
"Whoa dizzy."
Taking our number 8 spot is Kled, who, if we’re being honest is the embodiment of
your solo queue teammates.
"I find courage unpredictable, it's total insanity you can rely on!"
"I don't need a team to start a teamfight."
"Holy sh*t where are we?"
This Yordle and his semi-trusty mount Skaarl know exactly when to fight, that is all
the time.
"I'll kill em all!"
"Charge!"
Decorated, fearless and a little insane, Kled charges into every battle with only one goal
in mind — to rack up the kills.
"I might have to jump off this lizard and put my boot in your watoosie!"
"Sure, I'll kill all of em myself!"
"Shh. It's time to get violent."
"Weird."
But at the end of the day, it seems that all Kled wants to do is “reclaim” his land — or
more accurately, conquer the world.
"This land was made for me, and me alone."
"I'm from all over. It's next to nowhere and shut the hell up!"
Whether it’s his constant yelling ,
"My brain is full of weasels."
"The badgers demand your death."
or his love of tacos,
"After we finish murdering these folks, what do you think? Tacos? Yeah, tacos."
no one would argue with this Cantankerous Cavalier taking a spot on our list.
"I don't have trouble communicating, words is just treacherous bastards."
Our number seven champion may say his own name even more than even Draven.
"Mundo say his own name a lot, or else he forget! Has happened before."
"Mundo!"
This purple mad man has a flair for the completely insane
(laughs and slurps)
The monosyllabic monstrosity indiscriminately
smashes anything in his way no matter what lane you’re in.
"Mundo smash!"
"Mundo will go where he pleases!"
And still somehow manages
to find time to run an international corporation?
"Mundo runs international corporation as he pleases."
This deranged, demonized, denizen of Zaun has immortalized his voice in the world of
League of Legends.
"Mundo go this way!"
Why talk when you can just punch people?
Well, I guess if you’re Vi you can do both.
"Punch first, ask questions while punching.
Coming in at number 6 we have Piltover’s Finest — an ex-gang leader turned law enforcer.
Alongside partner Caitlyn, Vi nails the bad cop persona.
"Care for a spot of tea?"
"Or maybe a spot of punch in the face."
"We can either do this the hard way or... Oh wait no there's just the hard way."
Impulsive, short-tempered, and equipped with a pair of hextech gauntlets, this is a woman
you do not want to mess with.
"Why can't I get a straight answer, it's always just, 'Oh no stop hitting me! Ow my face.'"
"I let my hands do the talking."
She’s busting her way out of the jungle, dashing through your frontline and sending
you straight into the air.
"Yeah teamwork!"
"Vi, hah, stands for violence!"
This hextech powered peacekeeping punching-machine has smashed her way on to our list.
"Here I come to save the day... or wreck it."
"One girl wrecking crew."
The wispy, whimsical, and slightly boy crazy
"I'm not boy crazy, I just don't have a boyfriend yet."
cosmic herald of Targon, Zoe comes in at number
5 on our list.
"Something good is going to happen, with sparkles!"
"Nobody has to grow up if they don't want to!"
"Or maybe they do."
"I don't though."
After millennia playing within realities beyond human comprehension, The Aspect of Twilight
isn’t above having fun with her “Space Doggie.”
"Aww, I can hear my favorite wittle space doggy."
"Bad, bad space dragon! Bad!"
Or a good old fashion love triangle.
"Hi Ezreal! I mean- That is you over there, right? I'm over here. I'm Zoe... Never mind."
"I do not like yellow hair. And Demacia. And light magic. And everything about her!"
"But now how is he gonna be my first kiss? He's dead!"
But you’ll definitely think twice about taking her lightly if she catches you in a
Sleepy Trouble Bubble.
(Stream)
Zoe’s playful interactions with the rest of the cast have helped her
skip into the top 5 on our list.
"Heyyyy! I'm gonna have new friends, new friends here,
and it's gonna be awesome 'cause they are awesome
and we'll have an awesome party with cake and stuff!"
"Should I make chocolate mooncake or strawberry mooncake?
CHOCOLATE STRAWBERRY CAKE!!"
The Yordles that have made our list thus far may have all been a little crazy, but this
one takes the cake.
"Captain Teemo on duty."
For our number 4 spot we’re featuring the beloved Swift Scout, Teemo.
"Size doesn't mean everything."
"Never underestimate the power of the Scout's code."
Though small in stature with a cheerful personality, Teemo reminds us that looks can be deceiving.
"Turns out, I got a proficiency in killing."
"Killing's all I'm good at."
And with his time on the Omega Squad, it becomes quite obvious that this little guy is a stone
cold, natural-born killer.
"War didn't change me, I changed war!"
"Never. Get. Attached."
"Let the poison do its work."
"Sight. Shoot. Reload."
From his blinding blow darts to noxious mushroom traps, Teemo uses poison in various disturbing
ways, keeping you on your toes.
"Let 'em die slow."
Once sworn to the Bandle Scout’s Code, Teemo does not mess around when it comes to his
convictions.
"Some masks you never take off."
But war, war changes everyone.
"Nobody's innocent any more."
One of the first champions designed by Riot, Annie is a League of Legends staple
"You wanna play too? It'll be fun!"
And comes at number three on this list.
"Ashes, ashes, they all fall down."
While still a child, Annie is not afraid to dish it out with the most powerful mages
"Play time!"
"Eeny, meeny, miny, burn!"
"Don't be a scaredy cat!"
Alongside her teddy bear Tibbers
"Have you seen my bear Tibbers?"
who is equal parts cuddly and terrifying, Annie incinerates the competition with a quick flash ultimate.
"You smell like burning!"
"Get 'em, Tibbers!"
"Bear hug!"
"Yay, Tibbers!"
All with a skip in her step.
"Hop, skip, jump!"
"What's your favorite aminal? A bear?"
"Beaten by a little girl... ha!"
"I'm rubber and you're... on fire!"
Our runner up, is the maestro of mayhem and madness.
"Rules are made to be broken... like buildings! Or people!"
Jinx is known for causing chaos with her multitude of chemtech explosives and advanced weaponry.
"Stay still! I'm trying to shoot you!"
"Bullets!"
"What if I had a gun that... shot other guns?"
This blue-haired hellion will blow you up with
her Super Mega Death Rocket, laughing hysterically while she does it.
"No need to be scared - or alive."
"Bye bye!"
"See ya!"
"Catch!"
Jinx clearly loves what
she does.
"You know what I call five dead enemies?"
"A great start!"
"I killed Poppy! Who's next?"
And her joy, while twisted, is admirable?
"Guns don't kill people. I mean, until you shoot them. Then they kill everything!"
"I'm wearing lots of belts! For no reason at all."
Okay, she’s a lunatic.
"I'm crazy! Got a doctor's note."
But she at least keeps things interesting for Piltover’s
finest .
"Vi? Stands for stupid."
"Welcome to Snoresville, hat lady! Population: you."
"Now where was I? Oh, right, wreaking havoc!"
Okay guys, we lied in the intro.
It turns out that having a single cheeky one-liner will take you to the top of this list.
"Okay."
Because for our first place finish we have none other than the Armordillo RAMMUS!
"Yeah."
No one really knows what Rammus is.
"Hmm."
There are those who speculate that he’s the last of a dying species.
"Right."
The superstitious swear he’s a harbinger of change.
"Yeh."
Some even believe that he’s an Ascended being, an ancient god who rolls to Shurima’s
aid in its times of need.
"Alright."
We asked him about his thoughts on the rumors.
"Hmm."
"Yeah."
"Alright."
Well one thing’s for sure, Rammus will be rolling his way into your lane and there’s very
little you can do about it.
"Yeah."
(Casting)
"Ok."
Well guys that's our list for this week. Now if you didn't agree with it, I got one line for you.
"Shut your mouth hole!"
"Them badgers are listening."